Speaker 1: All right, a new challenger has
entered the Pennsylvania Senate race, and
it is television.
Dr. Mehmet Oz is known for being a purveyor
of quack cures and pseudoscience.
Can't even really call them treatments.
Really shouldn't even call them cures.
We're going to get to that television.
Dr. Mehmet Oz is running for Senate in Pennsylvania
as a Republican, and he's a complete disgrace
to the medical field.
And if he were a senator, it would be yet
another complete disgrace to this country.
But Trump won.
So Dr. Oz could certainly win.
There is a good candidate in that race, and
it's a really important race.
The good candidate is John Fetterman, lieutenant
governor of Pennsylvania.
And now we have a really bad candidate.
Dr. Oz has promoted all sorts of quack cures
for years.
He's the opposite of what we need in power,
and here is his big announcement that he is
running.
Speaker 2: My parents came to America to find
a better life, and they did.
I attended great universities, raised the
family and became a successful surgeon.
I invented a heart valve that saves thousands
of lives.
Then I started TV show The Advocate for you
taking control of your health, and took on
the medical establishment to argue against
cost drugs and skyrocketing medical bills.
But COVID has shown us that our system is
broken.
We lost too many lives, too many jobs and
too many opportunities because Washington
got it wrong.
They took away our freedom without making
us safer and tried to kill our spirit and
our dignity as a heart surgeon.
I know how precious like this Pennsylvanian
needs a conservative who put America first.
When you can reignite our divine spark, bravely
fight for freedom and tell it like it is.
That's why I'm running for Senate.
I'm Dr. Oz, and I approve this message.
Speaker 1: This is a major Senate race in
2022 in Pennsylvania.
This Senate race could decide who controls
the Senate in the next term, Democrats or
Republicans.
It's going to be an open seat, the incumbent
Republican Senator Pat Toomey, has said he's
not running for reelection.
Joe Biden won Pennsylvania in 2020, but Pennsylvania
is really a state that, particularly on Senate,
can go either way, even unpresidential.
It's not typically a big win for one side
or the other.
It's a fight.
And Dr. Oz is exactly the type of celebrity
that Republicans would love to vote for, and
he's truly horrible.
He has done a lot of horrible things on his
show, just as some examples.
He held a debate about gay reparative therapy
as if there's a legitimate conversation about
it.
This is like when a network says, we're going
to debate climate change and they bring on
someone who understands and states the facts
and someone else who just presents a completely
wacky conspiracy view and presents them as
if they are even Dr. Oz did the same thing
with gay reparative therapy.
Dr. Oz promoted green coffee bean extract
for weight loss.
There are no weight loss benefits to green
coffee bean extract.
It's one of these.
Purported things that has since been admitted
to being bogus.
He promoted the use of hydroxychloroquine
to treat COVID on multiple Fox News broadcasts,
and of course, as many of you know, I listed
hydroxychloroquine back at that time, along
with seven or eight other things that were
being looked at.
As does this work, the FDA revoked an EUA
for hydroxychloroquine, saying there was no
reason to believe that it was effective against
COVID 19.
He has been pushing.
Remember, he's an actual.
This is not like, you know what?
Oh, doctor, but it's not a medical doctor.
So you've got to this is a medical doctor,
and he still pushes nonsense.
Dr. Oz supportive of homeopathy, which is
just completely debunked.
I know some people in the audience get mad
at me.
Guys, it's totally debunked.
There's often no active ingredients in it
in measurable quantities.
It has been determined that homeopathy cannot
treat or cure any condition of any kind period.
It's just it's nothing.
OK, I'm sorry, guys.
There's just nothing.
Dr. Oz promoted energy therapies of different
kinds.
He's expressed support for faith healing.
He is kowtowed to psychic communication, and
much more of Dr. Oz has repeatedly claimed
that raspberry.
Oh man.
He has claimed that raspberry ketones are
the number one miracle in a bottle to burn
your fat.
He has said astrological signs may reveal
a great deal about your health and saying
that for centuries we've used astrological
signs to examine our personalities and how
we interact.
But there may be much to be revealed about
our health as well.
That's not true.
That's that's a lie.
Dr. Oz said that most countries require genetically
modified foods to be specially labeled, sort
of implying that it's because GMOs are unsafe.
Now, the reality is that most countries do
not require such labels.
GMO foods have been studied and have found
to be safe.
Now, the issue of pesticides is often intermingled
with GMO.
Pesticides are a different story.
But GMOs have been studied, and there's no
evidence that they are unsafe for human consumption.
There's something called USMCA Lobo.
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly.
It's a root extract.
And he says that it's been incredibly effective
at relieving cold symptoms, even though that's
not true, there are not reliable studies on
that.
And then remember when he said that, you know
what, if we open schools?
We might have two to three percent mortality,
but that would be a good trade.
What?
Remember this from April of 2020 on the Sean
Hannity program?
Speaker 2: Dr. Oz, help us.
Well, first we need our mojo back.
Let's start with things that are really critical
to the nation where we think we might build
open without getting into a lot of trouble.
I tell you, schools are a very appetizing
opportunity.
I just saw a nice piece in The Lancet arguing
that the opening of schools may only cost
us two or three percent in terms of total
mortality.
You know, that's any life was a life loss.
But to get every child back into a school
where they're safely being educated, being
fed and making the most out of their lives
with a theoretical risk on the back side might
be a tradeoff some folks would consider.
Speaker 1: Wow.
I mean, that's just completely bonkers.
First of all, once schools opened, we saw
that it was insane spread, and once a month
later, obviously schools opened and it was
just like immediately.
This entire classes has has to quarantine
to have Florida educators dying all over.
I mean, it's crazy.
Two to three percent mortality is a trade
off that we might make.
So you know, there was a point where we would
never imagine that a guy like this would have
a shot, except Donald Trump one.
And Dr. Oz could clearly win.
Dr. Oz could be the person who takes the Senate
from Democrats in 2022.
Now, fortunately, we have a great option,
and that's John Fetterman running in Pennsylvania.
This isn't an endorsement, but I like Fetterman.
We have good options is the point.
Pat Toomey is retiring, Republican senators
retiring, and it's not like it's Dr. Oz or
nobody.
We have, at minimum, John Fetterman.
I know there are other candidates running
on both the Democratic and Republican sides.
There will be primaries to choose who ultimately
makes it to the general election in November.
Now, only 11 months away.
Guys, it's it's the midterms.
We're in the midterms already, and that would
be an absolute disaster if Dr. Oz were to
win.
Let's next look at the welcome with open arms
that Dr. Oz received on Fox News over the
last 24 to 48 hours.